ha sido etiquetada como una crisis
humanitaria catastrófica mariupol la
bulliciosa ciudad portuaria del sur de
ucrania ahora se encuentra reducida a
escombros y cenizas las autoridades
locales informaron que al menos 5000
personas han sido enterradas y que
10.000 han perdido la vida y los cuerpos
tirados por
solo algunos de ellos estaban cubiertos
con mantas
pánico pánico destrucción escombros
heridos muertos llantos sangre gemidos
polvo por todas partes
el acceso a los suministros es
críticamente bajo el peor del país
160.000 civiles siguen rodeados por las
tropas rusas desesperados por alimentos
agua y medicinas
no hay comida para los niños
especialmente para los bebés tuvieron
que nacer los bebés en sótanos porque
las mujeres no tenían a dónde ir a dar a
luz todos los hospitales de maternidad
fueron destruidos
el bombardeo ruso que amnistía
internacional ha calificado de crimen de
guerra no deja de tener un valor
estratégico la resistencia en la ciudad
sitiada es el obstáculo clave que impide
que moscú obtenga el control completo de
los territorios de este don vas hasta
crimea ahora los habitantes locales que
cada vez son menos tienen que tomar una
decisión que pone en peligro sus vidas o
se quedan y resisten los bombardeos o
corren el riesgo de huir y quedar
atrapados en el fuego cruzado según el
presidente francés emmanuel macrón su
país junto con grecia y turquía esperan
lanzar una evacuación masiva en los
próximos días pero eso dependería de
cómo avancen las conversaciones con
vladimir putin sobre la apertura de un
corredor humanitario